everyone this is kevin from the chest
website com wanted to make a quick video
to update everyone on the new website it
was launched this morning some of you
who frequent the site very often if
probably already in it some of you may
not even know that I created a website
but this is the new website the chest
website com it's got a new look to it
for those who remember the old design
this is much cleaner as you can see the
footer has a lot more options so just
wanted to let everyone know if you
haven't been to the website in a while
I've added a few new sections so
definitely check those out at the bottom
just want to let y'all know for those
who are used to coming to the website
and looking at the updates the updates
is now at the bottom so if you want to
see the new things that have been added
to the website you can click on this a
lot of people always ask me for my
contact information you can click on the
contact button right here and lastly
there is a ton of different stuff that I
could go over about the new features on
the website but one thing I did want to
point out because a lot of people have
asked is the chest DVD section I am now
making the DVD that I make on YouTube
available for purchase again everything
on the website is free so don't feel
like you have to buy the dvds but many
people have expressed interest now until
the end of October so you haven't
October thirty-first I'm going to go
ahead and throw in a free gift the
famous chess games analyzed so if you
really enjoy the famous chess games and
you want to go ahead and get the full
set i'm going to go ahead and throw that
in there so the entire set right now is
eight dvds it's quite a lot of material
so if you want to go ahead and do that
you can go ahead and get that on the DVD
section right here keep in mind most of
the enhancements on the website have
been from user feedback so if you see
anything that you like that you don't
like that you want to see added
definitely feel free to let me know